vous permettrait d'avoir d'avoir un
premier mot pour nos 150 mille militants
qui se sont mobilisés comme comme jamais
la droite est de retour merci pour eux
merci
la droite a retrouvé son adn elle est
populaire est allé solidaire comme on
l'est mais très très attaché à ses
valeurs et puis surtout avec maintenant
une vraie équipe de france serait prête
à gouverner prêt à diriger notre pays
c'est donc aujourd'hui pour nous une
formidable
formidable journée journée de
rassemblement jour ni journée d'union
d'unités pour la pour la nation et puis
surtout c'est le jour où nous posons le
premier pas sur le chemin qui va nous
amener à la victoire